un pedido mundial e inmediato salvar a
la humanidad en la primera jornada de
ccoo 26 en glasgow el secretario general
de naciones unidas dijo que los países
deben actualizar sus compromisos
climáticos anualmente no cada cinco años
basta de matarnos con el carbono basta
de tratar la naturaleza como un retrete
basta de quemar perforar y minar a mayor
profundidad estamos cavando nuestra
propia tumba digging ahora un grave
durante el evento los líderes mundiales
discutirán los nuevos compromisos para
combatir la emergencia climática y
lograr el objetivo de no elevar la
temperatura del planeta más allá de los
15 grados celsius en el siglo 21
la impaciencia del mundo serán
incontenibles a menos que hagamos de
esta cop 26 en blasco el momento en el
que nos pongamos en serio con el cambio
climático
para la canciller alemana la lucha
climática pasa por ponerle un impuesto
global a las emisiones de carbono abogó
por que seamos más ambiciosos a nivel
nacional pero que también encontremos
instrumentos a nivel global que no sólo
utilicen el dinero de los contribuyentes
sino que sean económicas razonables para
mí esto es la tarificación del co2 entre
las metas abordadas cumplir con las
ayudas anuales de 100 mil millones de
dólares destinados a los países del sur
global una promesa hasta ahora
incumplida pese a que data de 2009
y de está perfecta hoy es casi seguro
que los países de áfrica del pacífico de
américa latina de américa del sur y del
caribe que más lo necesitan no son los
que se benefician de la mayor parte de
esta financiación por ello más allá de
nuestros anuncios debemos tener también
transparencia en el seguimiento del uso
de estos 100 mil millones de dólares
anuales la utilización de si son
medianos desde ahora para o por su parte
el mandatario estadounidense anunció
algunos de los nuevos retos de este país
después de regresar al acuerdo de parís
vamos a reducir las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero de eeuu en más de
una gigantón helada para 2030 un día por
su parte tendrá como objetivo cero
emisiones netas para 2070 dos décadas
después de lo que pide la onu que sigue
avanzar la reducción a 2050 un reto de
talla mundial